hey there everybody welcome to another
well welcome to a new year and a new
episode of ask a career coach thank you
all for joining us live on YouTube
really excited to get your questions
today and work together with everyone to
kick this year off right so if you are
just joining us
please start adding your questions into
the chat we will be collecting them and
going through them one by one looks like
we have about 12 people here right now
but I'm going to wait a few minutes for
you to shout out where you're from in
the chat and start putting in your
questions before we get started I want
to just get a heads up so or just I
guess introduce myself my name is Martin
McGovern I'm a career adviser here at
Udacity my background is in marketing so
a lot of what we're gonna be talking
about today is the more promotional side
of the job search rather than the
technical side I can answer a few of the
technical things but I'm not a developer
myself so there might be a few questions
I won't be able to go to as deep into
but when it comes to getting noticed
putting together your online portfolios
your brand getting in front of people
networking acing the interview all those
kinds of things please add in your
questions and you know this is going to
be a fun one since this is January 3rd
it's a first one of the new year start
adding your new year resolution into the
chat because that's all we're gonna be
kicking off the conversation with what
are your resolutions and if you have any
resolutions are they specific are they
more theme based you know we'll get into
it
but I'm excited to chat with you all
today and answer all of your questions
I'll give just a few minutes for people
to join and then we'll jump right into
it
wolverhampton is that someone's name or
that a location that's really cool
I'm just following along here as we wait
to get let allow people to join all
right we got someone from London digital
marketing nanodegree thank you for
joining us Dora coda get placed Thank
You Sanji for your actually from the job
all right we got Canada we got Zurich
Switzerland all right it looks like
we're getting up to the 60s in attendees
so I'm gonna start jumping into
questions again thank you everyone for
joining if you're just joining us right
now we are collecting questions as well
as new year resolutions if you have them
and we're going to be jumping into our
New Year's career discussion so the
first thing that I wanted to chat about
today as we're getting into the
questions is the idea of you know
getting ready for a new year we just
posted a video today about and last week
about making networking a New Year's
resolution as well as how to decide what
you want to be doing next in your career
what I find is that a lot of folks are
reaching out and just saying what should
I do and it's kind of hard to give
answers you know when there's not as
much context and you know I'm not you
I'm not in your head but there are a few
things that we can do to make the entire
journey a little bit easier one of the
hardest things about trying to make a
decision around your career especially
as we go into a new year is a the idea
of lots of possibilities right the world
is our oyster but the problem is is that
when you have so many options you can do
this that the other thing you can live
here there or wherever when you
have all these options it's really
difficult to decide which option to
afford with because we don't want to
eliminate things where there's there's a
fear inside a lot of us to make about
making the wrong choice and eliminating
options down the road but the problem is
is this concept of analysis paralysis
and in the video that we just shared
recently earlier today actually if
you're walking on the toothpaste aisle
and you're looking at all the different
toothpastes and one says tartar control
and you know whitening and the other one
says a number of other things how do you
actually compare these different things
there's too many variables there's too
many different types of toothpaste it's
overwhelming and so what we have to do
is just kind of trust our gut and go
with what we think is right we'll figure
out whether it was right or wrong as we
go and learn and do the thing when it's
just in our head as a bunch of ideas
floating around but when we're actually
doing it when we're talking to people to
do the job we're trying out projects on
our own we really learned pretty quickly
if it's right or wrong so for instance
you know when I was younger and I
thought I want to go into graphic design
I started designing logos for people
just friends bands small businesses and
I quickly learned it was not the thing
that I wanted to be doing because it was
a just not the way my brain functions
sitting there for 10 hours creating a
logo but those are the things that we
start to realize once we do it it sounds
great in your head but once you're doing
it once you're practicing it you'll find
out pretty quickly if it's right or
wrong so I encourage all of you as we go
into this new year to spend less time
thinking and more time doing the things
that you're curious about or suspect to
be the right answer and then when you
find out it's right you keep going with
it and if you find out it's not quite
right for you you delete it and never
look back so for instance these videos
something that I enjoy doing but you
know I'm finally really digging in so
that's what we're all working on we're
all just trying to find that thing that
makes us be like yeah I'm this is what I
enjoy doing and so give a shout in the
comments if you already have a suspicion
of what that thing is for you and let's
dedicate
ourselves in the coming year to
confirming Orden
confirming or saying it's not right not
the right way to give them alright so
we've got some great questions coming in
thank you for listening through the
intro here and thank you so much for
joining the career Q&A today let's jump
on in all right
rayon Malick you have dumb digital
marketing nanodegree
how can you land a job at a job or an
internship at Google or Facebook or
other multinationals this is a great
question so one of the questions one of
the things that I'm getting from this
question is that you really want to work
at a large company a very very large
tech company Google and Facebook two of
the biggest in the world right so my
question to you is why do you want to
work at a large company do you want to
work a large company because of the name
brand or do you want to work at a large
company because of the culture of being
in a very large company or you know what
is it what is your driving motivation
and then when you're thinking about
Google Facebook or other multinationals
they're going to ask you why do you want
to work here and if you say I want to
work here because it's a big company or
because it has great brand value that
will improve my personal you know value
in the market place of jobs like having
Google on my resume would be really cool
that's not a great answer as to why you
want to work at Facebook or Google and
honestly that is a lot of people's
answers because almost everyone I talked
to says they want to work at Google or
Facebook and it's just because it's the
most obvious thing that we all use on a
regular day-to-day basis so it's not a
bad thing but dig a little deeper into
yourself and figure out what part of
Facebook are you most interested in
working at what part of Google are you
most interested in working at a good
example I can give of this as I was
working with someone who realized
throughout our conversations that they
were their background was in linguistics
and so they wanted to work at Amazon and
Google
not because it's Amazon and Google but
because Amazon and Google were the two
biggest companies in the voice search
space right they wanted to work on sauna
Google home and they wanted to work on
Alexa my Luck's gonna try and talk to me
now and so those are the things sorry
Maya Lex is trying to talk to me it's
gonna keep doing that keep saying the
name but what what ended up happening
was they once they realized that their
search expanded because they realized
that it wasn't necessarily Google and
Amazon that they're interested in it was
that voice technology and just
everything with programming and and and
voice search and the future of that and
so what they were able to do is really
expand their search out to say I'm
curious about what the world will look
like when everyone is talking to their
devices all day long and now they're
talking to you know Google Facebook who
else is making voiced of a how the cars
at some point you know just interacting
with your vehicle there's all sorts of
different things that they can type into
so to answer your question the first
thing you need to do is figure out why
you want to work at these companies and
not because of you but because of what
you can do for them he can bring
linguistics and programming background
to helping these companies create more
human interactions with their voice
systems so for you I would say figure
that out and then look at your network
do you know anyone who works these
companies if you don't that is your next
step how do I meet as many people who
work at these companies as I possibly
can and develop relationships with them
whether you're doing coding like
challenges together whether you're just
getting coffee and chatting the the real
way that these companies hire because
they're so big because they have such an
internal network is through internal
referrals the prop probably the absolute
majority of people who get jobs these
companies know someone who works at this
company so if you don't know anyone who
works at the company the chances of
getting in are extremely low you're not
you're probably not going to get in
through just
LinkedIn posting a job board it's
possible but it's the likelihood as low
and what you're asking here is how do
you increase your likelihood it's by
getting to know people who work at those
companies in those jobs so do those two
things and that's a good starting point
to getting on the right track for that
goal thank you so much for your question
Rupesh is learning AI worthwhile in 2019
hmm
so I want to reiterate I'm not I'm not a
technical person I'm more of a marketing
and promotional person career
development things like that but I think
we can't dig into this question a little
bit and see see if we can help you here
so is learning AI worthwhile in 2019 I
think it is I think that there is a lot
going on in the AI space and it's also
an interesting differentiator when
you're out talking to people during your
job search when you're networking when
you're going into you know interviews
different conversations now you have to
realize that AI is a very large term it
encompasses a lot of different
technologies that people kind of bundle
into that one title right so when when
you think is it worthwhile for 2019 I
also need to figure out what your goals
are in 2019 if you would like to be
someone who's involved in artificial
intelligence over the next decade to two
decades a hundred percent this is a
great time to start so that you're you
know getting in before that whole
snowball starts rolling down the hill if
it's just something that you find
interesting you're trying to jump on a
trend trends come and go and if that's
not truly where your interest lies you
might find yourself you know having
spent a lot of money learning something
and then you know it's still five years
away from becoming mainstream and you
have to go learn something else in the
short term so if this is something that
you're really curious about over the
long term I definitely think you should
pursue it but if it's something that
you're just trying to then
to sit in or want to explore figure out
what your shortest term goal is and
focus on that first and then maybe start
building your AI knowledge over time so
it kind of depends on where you want to
go with it I mean there's people working
in the AI industry so if that's where
you want to be and you want to be at the
forefront of that technology competing
for those jobs go for it Sanjeet I'm
looking for a job in a foreign country
what should I do
I don't have much experience this is
going to be very contingent on the
country you're trying to move to and the
country that you're in so if you want to
share that in the chat maybe we can add
a little bit more detail into this
question by the end of the call but hmm
it's really tough to like I saw where
I'm in America right and trying to get
from one state to another is a fairly
difficult thing for some people because
they don't have the network there they
don't they don't have the built-in and
like we've said on a lot of these calls
80% of jobs are found through networking
so if you don't have a network in the
area you're moving you have to first
build the network and then get into the
job now there are cases where you don't
need the network but chances are you
need to meet someone who works in that
area even if it's the hiring manager for
the role you want so how do you get a
job in a new country gosh I've never
done it myself so it's hard for me to
really give a lot of context on this one
if anyone in the chat here because we
have over a hundred people here from all
over the world if you have gotten a job
in another country connect with Sanji
and see if you two can talk about
strategies for how to do that it would
definitely start with building a network
in that country maybe moving there and
then building a network I'm not sure
what your you know financial resources
are or family situation so it
it's a bit too complex of a question for
me to fully answer here but let's try
and bring it into the chat see if we can
help each other and see if maybe we can
even take this into slack later and get
super specific but thank you so much for
your question Sanjeet hopefully we can
get you a little bit more information in
the chat all right we have Alena here I
completed my data analyst nanodegree not
what should be my next step to getting
hired as an analyst
well it's awesome bravo for completing
your degree thank you for getting out
there and learning new things and
continuing to upskill yourself I think
that's an awesome awesome way to move in
any career you're in what should you do
next
the next thing is to look at your
network and say do I know any data
analysts and most of the time when I ask
that question to people they say they
know one or two if you only know a
couple of data analysts then you're
really not you know immersed in the
group that you're trying to join so what
you need to do is take a bit of a
learning from the quote you are the five
people you spend the most time with if
no one in your network is a data analyst
chances are it's going to be a bit of an
uphill run in order to go meet those
people and get into that circle so the
first thing I would do now that you've
completed your nano degree is go build
your network go to LinkedIn is actually
a pretty simple thing to do go to
LinkedIn go to the search bar normally
everyone goes to jobs because that's why
we go to LinkedIn but there's also a
search bar for people so if you go to
people and you type in data analysts it
will filter all the data analysts that
are connected to your linkedin network
it'll probably be like hundreds of
thousands of people to start but then go
into the other filters on your LinkedIn
profile and filter by your location so
your
city your city area and then filter by
any industries that you're interested in
and you can go to google and look up
LinkedIn industry codes in order to see
all the different industries but at
least filter by your location in the job
title and that should get you down to
20,000 people maybe 5,000 people they do
the job that you wish you were doing and
then what you can do is start reaching
out to those people I recommend starting
by finding their emails and using a
website like find that dot email or any
of the other kinds of Yellow Pages for
emails that are online and connecting
with people in order to learn how they
got their job in the field and then also
just build a relationship with them what
do they enjoy doing what are they
excited about what are they struggling
with and when you build relationships
with people who work in the field you
want to be in eventually you're gonna
meet people who have a need and when you
see like hey what are you struggling
with and they say you know I really wish
I was working on this project but I'm
always caught up in the day-to-day of
this you could say hey you know I could
come on as contractor maybe help out
with that PC you can focus on the Nexen
and whether it's an internship a
contract or a lower full-time role
you'll get a lot more traction reaching
out to real people rather than online
job loads so I would highly recommend
you take it in that direction thank you
so much for your crash your question
Alena alright thank you everyone thank
you for putting in your questions here
we've got a lot porn and I'm really
excited to get into these
all right Anastasia I have a job
interview next week as a game developer
Bravo everyone give a round of applause
in the comments just clap it up put some
emojis down there for Anastasia she's
gotten an interview coming up I love it
just graduated be the Fen nanodegree the
front-end nanodegree I don't have any
personal projects or experience what to
point out at the interviews so I would
pass the interview all right well the
first thing is I want to congratulate
you for getting the interview that's so
awesome
especially when you're you know saying
your personal projects an experience I
are at the point they're at you still
got the interview you're crushing it so
now we got to figure out what you need
to do in order to pass the interview I
was working with someone recently about
this and when it comes to at least the
behavioral interview the behavioral
interview is really about giving
specific answers to questions that show
you can do the job in the future so you
might say and I honestly I think you're
putting yourself down a little bit more
than you should be you say I don't have
any personal projects or experience you
definitely have some experience you've
taken a nano degree you understand the
software enough in order to get an
interview so you've done enough to get
in the door so now you just need to
build rapport and showcase you know a
little bit more of yourself so it's not
it's not I would just say own where
you're at you're at the interview stage
so you're doing a good job when you are
thinking about behavioral interviews
what you want to think about is what
stories can I tell that will showcase
that I can do this job so look back at
you know the time you spent in your nano
degree any other jobs you've had
throughout your life what are some of
the moments where you've had a lot of
success or you've had a hard failure or
a mix of the two like the stories that
pop in your head when you think
things that I enjoyed or maybe didn't
enjoy about past roles then when they
ask you questions try and answer those
questions
with concrete examples so what you want
to avoid when someone says hey tell me a
time that you struggled in your career
you the typical way someone would answer
that question is well there was this
time I worked in a job and I struggled
and then I overcame it and I'm good well
you didn't tell me any details
who did you struggle with what was the
struggle about how did you approach
solving it what were the wins what were
the losses well you know what were the
outcomes so what you want to do is say a
specific time that I struggled and
you're you really only need like three
or four good stories because every story
has highs and lows and and story arcs
and multiple story arcs so what you want
to think about is all right there is
this one time I was working at a company
and me and Sally had a really tough
interaction right who was Sally why did
you have a tough interaction what was
the project that you were trying to
accomplish I was talking with someone
recently and they said they worked on a
project once at boot camp and the
partner that they were working on the
project with was extremely like neurotic
and I use that as a technical term so
what ended up happening was within like
two days of starting this project the
guy was already saying oh no we're never
gonna finish this we're gonna have to
extend our time in this program I don't
have the money for it I'm gonna fail
this whole thing now what's cool is the
person I was talking to had a background
in therapy so they were able to stay
this like calm Center bring the person
down from there kind of freak out and
calm everyone down so that they can
actually finish the project to keep
moving forward and get it done on time
so that shows leadership skills it shows
their past skill set helping their
current skill set therapy helping the
programming work and all of that kind of
mixed together so the prop the the thing
they were trying to accomplish was a
project the issue that arose was someone
freaking out his approach to a solution
was bringing his therapy knowledge in to
calm the person down and they were able
to get to the solution
and that would answer the question in a
behavioral interview of you know what's
a time you struggle to the co-worker or
what's the time you've shown leadership
skills or any number of different
questions that that story could answer
so get a tape recorder on your phone
wherever and try and pull up a list of
the top 30 interview questions and see
if you have two or three stories that
you can tell that will answer multiple
questions and just say them and just
practice it and listen to it back and
practice it and listen to it back it'll
be really helpful for you as you go into
this behavioral interview and then on
the technical side go to the websites
that allow you to practice white
boarding tests and things like that if
you have a white boarding interview
coming up reach out to people and slag
people in the chat here and see if you
can help each other alright thank you so
much Anastasia and Bravo on landing an
interview I'm really excited for you I
hope I hope you message us back at some
point and let us know you got it alright
it looks like our next two questions are
related to the last one so I'm gonna
read through them and see if we can add
to it at all
all right the first one by Michael Ling
thank you so much for sharing question
here I'm gonna focus on are the projects
from Udacity enough those you said those
projects look just like an assignment
from college alright are the projects
from Udacity enough I think anytime you
get to a point where you think you have
enough you should probably start
building something new we live in an age
of content information and constant
learning throughout your life so the
reason I push back on this is if you say
it is enough and you stop and then four
or five months go by and you're you know
job searching or whatever and you
haven't done any other work it's going
to show a big gap in your github or
whatever it is that you're using to
record this information so I would say
it's not enough I would say you always
need to be building something working on
something exploring new things learning
new things as long as you don't use that
as an excuse not to job search I don't
want you to fall into the productive
procrastination like hole where you're
learning things and building things but
you haven't applied for a job in three
months you need to be doing both you
need to be learning a bit during the day
and then you need to be applying and
networking and things like that during
the day and keep going back and forth so
if you have any ideas of small things to
build while you're doing your job search
it will not only keep your online
profiles fresh but give you lots of
things to talk about while networking
and interviewing so keep keep building
all right
Abhishek how can I land a job and should
I pursue a full-stack course I've done
my front-end nanodegree program I'm
gonna just touch on that productive
procrastination piece again if you feel
like you're out there and you're
networking and you're applying for jobs
and you're doing all the right things in
your job search
you can keep learning on the side but
don't use learning to procrastinate your
job search so I would highly recommend
getting out there and starting to
network in job search and then if you
want to keep learning outside keep doing
that all right any tips on networking
for a remote job sorry drink a little
too much water
too quickly there all right
Mariana any tips for networking for a
remote job this a lot goes into this but
probably the best things you can do in
order to network in an area that you
don't live is to connect with people
online in any way that they are
interacting online so you might need to
get good at a number of different types
of online outreach so I know someone who
does a ton of networking on Twitter and
they get a lot of clients they're in
sales it's something that they spend a
lot of time on and they've gotten jobs
just through Twitter I've also seen
someone else who works in the art world
and they do a ton of networking on
Instagram and they have friends all over
the country and connections all over the
place so when something comes up in
their area jobs get past their way so
that's where they do their networking I
also see a ton of people do a lot of
networking via LinkedIn setting up Skype
calls I think that's definitely a good
way to go and then a really great way to
connect with people online is to go to
people's blogs or medium posts or
LinkedIn profiles blogs medium posts and
LinkedIn profiles and comment and
interact with them around the things
that they're posting about so if you you
know go to their profile and they're
sharing articles comment on the article
is comment on the things that they write
on medium and try to build a rapport and
anytime you can try and turn that into a
I call or something along those lines or
you can ask them questions about their
work and what they're and what they're
doing get their advice and I would say
the best possible way to network for
remote job is to build some sort of side
hustle side project that you can use as
an excuse to meet people so for instance
let's say you create a podcast around
sports technology and then you reach out
to all the CEOs and VPS and managers at
sports companies that you want to work
for and you just interview them for your
sports tech podcast and you get all of
their you know insights and information
the next time they're thinking about
hiring a developer or whatever it is
that you do you can that you're gonna be
the first person in their head because
you've already given them value you've
helped create a conversation that they
can share with their network and all
that other good stuff so there's a lot
of great ways to work remotely but I
think or to network while remote but I
think it kind of comes down to what
you're comfortable with and then also
building your comfort level and your
activity on different online profiles
where people are already talking about
the things that you're interested in all
right Anthony Alvarez how can job
seekers do more outbound job search any
suggestions and recommendations this is
a great question we actually created a
video about this it's the difference
between a passive job search and an
active job search most people are
passive they wait for LinkedIn to send
them a list of 10 job listings and then
they go yeah I'll apply to the bread
company and the sheet company and the
car company and then their brain is
going in circles doing back flips saying
wait are we interested in bread or are
we interested in shoes or are we
interested in cars I don't understand
what we're trying to say that we're
trying to accomplish because what's
going to happen in all these different
conversations always different
interviews they're gonna say why do you
want to work for us and if you're making
up a new story of why you want to work
there is going to get very awkward so
the best way to do it is to focus your
job search on a specific industry and
then reach
out to as many people who are in that
industry as you possibly can so a good
example is I knew someone who wanted to
get into the internet-of-things industry
so they reached out to the parts
manufacturers they reached out to the
nest companies they reached out to the
refridgerator companies that reach out
to GE all everyone everyone who's
involved and by the 10th conversation
they were the smartest person when it
came to Internet of Things because they
had so many different perspectives so if
you want to do an outbound job search
know what job title you want and know
what industry you want to be in and then
really just go talk to as many people as
possible as you're talking learn what
problems that they have and eventually
you will find a solution that pops up or
it actually and at the end of each
conversation ask if there's anyone else
that they would recommend you connect
with and ask in the future would you be
open to passing along my resume and then
create notifications for all those
companies that you've met with and when
jobs pop up you reach out to that person
they refer you boom you're you're on
your way to a job
please show the Twitter LinkedIn and
blogs of people that you mentioned I
think when you see real-life examples
Anthony I'd like to but I also want to
protect their privacy these are just
people that I know people that are
working on their own things one thing I
can say is I can start digging into this
a little bit more and create some career
tip videos that show some examples for
you in the future so I'm gonna put that
to the side and try and try and get some
people who have agreed to allow me to
share their examples so if anyone out
there is doing this please reach out to
me share examples and we will use that
to build a little more context around
what I'm talking about here I just I
don't want to share some of my friends
and things like that it without their
permission
so I appreciate that follow-up and I'll
try I'll try my best to get some
real-life examples for you
all right
Kaitlyn I graduated from the abnd
now looking for a developer job I can't
find any positions that I can commute to
I've also been having a hard time
finding junior positions that are remote
mmm it is going to be difficult to find
junior positions that are remote we did
a series on remote work we have about
three videos on the Udacity career tips
playlist on YouTube one of the things
that I found when I was talking to
people who have remote jobs is that they
were able they got the remote job by
turning their in-person job into a
remote job over time so they would work
from home one day a week then two days a
week then three days a week and then
eventually they work from home that's
difficult to do because you have to get
the job first and work there for a while
build credibility and then be able to
make that transition thankfully there
are lots and lots of companies who are
now entirely remote or at least more and
more I'm not sure how many are out there
but being a remote worker is becoming
more and more common hmm it's hard to do
as a junior role though because they
want you in there being trained by the
team and learning all their processes
and different things of that sort so it
may be difficult to find those promote
junior positions if you could follow up
in the chat with where you live that we
might be able to get a little bit more
detailed here if if there's truly
nothing that you can commute to meaning
you're 2 to 3 hours outside a city and
there's not really that many jobs around
you something on those lines you may
need to consider moving of course I
don't know your life circumstances so
it's hard to you know really give that
as a strong as a strong point but that
is something that you have to sort of
figure out when you're defining what you
want to do as a job are you willing to
commute two hours or are you willing to
move or are you willing to what are the
things right there are a lot of
different things that come along with a
job and sometimes we have to adjust our
life
around the job if that's what we want to
do if that's the most important priority
need a little bit more information there
but I hope that was able to kind of push
towards an answer for you all right
IT Pro how can we find apprenticeships
and as a Udacity grad when they are not
posted Prentiss ships hmm it's a really
good question I think sometimes because
apprenticeship is not a common job
search term it's not you know there's no
like website that just lists tech
apprenticeships or at least not that I
know if you know of one please add it in
the chat and share it with everyone so
we can add it to our our tool belts are
our bat belts and as you might say and
our utility belt as those like that I
would start by looking at companies that
are hiring for entry-level and
internship roles and when I say looking
at it I mean when you see a job posting
typically a company is hiring for more
than just the one job so you can kind of
take the job posting as a little red
flag that says hey our company is
growing our company is looking for help
so what you can do is you can say
alright if they are looking for help in
this area they probably have needs in
other areas I'm gonna go talk to people
who have the job title that I wish I had
and I'm gonna start getting a you know
building a network in that area then you
can ask them if they do apprenticeships
now a lot of people won't know what that
means but they might just call it an
internship or they might call it - what
was it like a rotational program there's
a lot to our names for it so I would
that's going to be something that you're
gonna find by talking to people you're
probably not going to just find it's
probably not going to just fall in your
lap so if that's really what you want if
you want an apprentice
I hope maybe some folks have some
websites that do post these kinds of
things I've not seen a ton of them but
that's gonna be something you're going
to get by by talking people saying I'm
looking to be an apprentice and maybe
you can be an apprentice just someone
who's got a startup that's really
interesting that you'd like to to join
who knows
oh how pay yang I I'm sorry I'm terrible
at names so if I'm pronouncing your
names wrong I really apologize I'm
working on getting better at it if
there's actually if anyone has resources
on how to be better at pronouncing names
I'm open to him because I'm trying to
learn and I appreciate you saying call
me coach that's cool hey coach what are
the challenges of working remotely what
do companies look for in a good remote
engineer the things that companies are
looking for in someone who works
remotely our consistency communication
and responsibility just in general so if
you're someone who wants to be a remote
worker you you it's the best possible
thing you can have is a track record of
remote work like you know I used to run
my own business or I you know have
worked remote for other companies that's
gonna be the most solid thing that will
set you up for finding a remote role in
the future
the next most solid thing is to have
some sort of like blog or online profile
that you're updating on a regular basis
if let's say you have a YouTube channel
and you update it every single day for a
year
it shows that you're consistent and
you're not going to just disappear for a
week and leave them humming and dry so
those are the kinds of things they want
to make sure that you're consistent that
you're reliable and that you're
responsible and all that kind of stuff
so when you're the more you can do to
create your online presence that is
human a good picture on your Linkedin a
bunch of videos so that I can watch them
and actually see what you look like so
I'm never gonna see you in person
writing and sharing and updating your
github like all these things are going
to be the things that mark you as a
reliable person on the internet and
that's like if you ever are trying to
find I don't know a plumber and you go
to their website and there's no ratings
and reviews and they haven't updated
their blog in ten years and there's no
face attached with the name are you
gonna really want to hire
you want to hire a plumber who has like
a video on their website saying I'm
gonna be your plumber I'm going to show
up you want to hire the person there's a
hundred thousand reviews and they're 4.5
and above you're gonna want to hire the
person that you know you're your friend
has hired and they've done a good job
all those kinds of things so the more
you can humanize your online presence
and the other way to put that is to
build a personal brand the easier it's
going to be to get a remote job and then
you're gonna figure out how to target
companies that hire remote workers not
every company does but more and more are
so really spend your time trying to
figure out well who does remote remote
hit up be like reddit about finding
remote work I'm sure there's a ton of
great resources there as well and just
do do more research I appreciate you
asking this question it's definitely a
tough one it's it's one that most people
who work remote it's like a serendipity
thing or something that they
progressively get closer to over time
it's hard to just start in a remote role
when you've not had any experience doing
it but again it's something that you can
accomplish as long as you you spend the
time alright and
got four questions here that are all
related to confidence let me see here
and is this the right time
Dimitri be a couple of no names let's
see freshly graduated and doing projects
I want to help career start data science
is it right to do it now
I started data science to get better at
data insights is it right to do this now
fused to know what city I'm interested
in so I'm just reading up on there's a
lot of questions here that are all kind
of related all right so the first thing
I wanna address here is I graduated from
a flying car nano degree assist me tree
but I don't feel confident in my skills
to apply for a new job my background is
softener Engineering but I've never
worked for robotics so the first thing
that I want to tackle here is the
concept of experience experience is not
something that is only related to the
very narrow specific title that you're
applying to as a matter of fact most
people who are applying for a job I've
never done that job before that's why
they're applying for it they've done
other things that have set them up to be
good for that role but they've never
actually done that role if they were
doing that role they wouldn't be needing
to apply for that role
so when it comes to experience you have
to take into account all of your
experience any internships you've done
projects you've done education you've
gotten all of that plays towards your
experience and then you need to practice
talking about that experience and how
you've developed as a professional over
time if you go in and you think you have
zero experience it's going to show so we
do need to tackle that and the way that
you tackle that is by sitting down and
writing out all of your accomplishments
over time what were the things that I
learned what were the things that I
built how did people enjoy working with
me I was working with someone the other
day and they were you know feeling
really bad about their their job because
they
I really wanted to move into PR and they
worked in recruiting but they couldn't
get into PR because everyone knew them
as recruiter and didn't want them to you
know leave the team so they actually got
blocked from a number of different jobs
because they couldn't get into because
the team wanted them there and so they
were looking at it very negatively we
actually have to change that and say
wait a second people like working with
me so much that they're blocking me from
getting a different job because they
want me to keep working on this they
like my work that is a positive thing
that now we can take as motivation to go
find that next role and find a way to
circumvent these blockers so when you're
approaching the job search start it
start approaching it from I need to
learn what it takes to become a flying
car to work in the flying car and
robotics industry so if you approach it
from I need to learn what it takes to
get into robotics all your conversations
are talking to people about what's your
background how did you get into this
what are the things that you know you
would recommend that I do if you ask for
advice your chances of getting a job go
up if you ask for a job your chances of
getting a job goes down so you always
want to ask for advice not a job so then
what you can say is all right I've
talked to a dozen people and this is
something that actually happens in
advertising quite a lot so if you talk
to a dozen people and you realize oh I
actually do know this like you know
you'll find out that these people that
you sort of look at and think are the
smartest people on earth are all doing
the same thing you're doing they're
trying to learn they're trying to stay
on top of trends they're trying to just
you know get their work done go home and
be with their family so you'll find out
pretty quickly as you talk to people
where you stand in the entry-level to
senior level and you'll also see oh the
people that are entry-level or intern or
whatever it is that you're trying to do
are pretty much like me
so I do have the chops if you find that
you truly don't have the chops then you
have to say how do I get the chops and
go do a little bit more education or
build a few projects or whatever you
need to do get there so you build
confidence by talking
and by doing the work if you're just
sitting here in your head giving
yourself negative talks about not being
good enough let other people tell you
that you shouldn't get the job don't
tell yourself have a little bit more
faith in your ability to accomplish I
mean you already graduated the nano
degree which means you have enough chops
to graduate a nano degree and that is a
step in the right direction so you're
already doing a great job just keep it
up and any time you're getting those
negative thoughts just try and be like
hey I hear you but I need to move in
this direction so we're moving forward
then that's the other question in this
same topic is the company is saying you
need more experience and my question to
that is are these actual people that
you're talking to who are saying you
don't have the experience where are
these reply like automated replies from
job boards saying you don't have enough
experience if they're real people then
ask the people what do I need to do to
get enough experience and that will give
you the answer of what you need to do in
order to be able to make the move into
this area if it's a job board thing go
talk to real people like the job board
automated emails that's just what goes
out to everyone so don't spend too much
time worried about that stuff if a real
person tells you you're not qualified
first of all assess whether or not they
are qualified to be telling you if
you're qualified and then second ask
them point blank what do I need to do
and and and then you'll you'll actually
have a plan I think a lot of this stuff
comes from not having a set plan so if
you actually write down like here's what
I need to do in order to get there
it really makes things easier
so we have a question here and it's not
I don't have a name with it but it says
I'm confused
to know what suits me I'm interested in
artificial intelligence and started to
learn but sometimes I did not enjoy or
feel comfortable and I'm afraid it won't
suit what can I do
gosh that's a hard questions I just
don't have enough information but when
it comes to figuring out if something
suits you you have to separate your
interest in the industry and the topic
and the future of that thing and how it
helps people and what it could be from
the day-to-day work grind struggle
boring stuff making these videos and
talking to you is super fun but editing
videos and researching stuff and I mean
that's not nearly as much fun right so
and also writing emails and do not it's
like there's a whole job around the
thing that you're interested in the
question is what do you find most
interesting intellectually that makes
the pain worth it so if you're following
things that are intellectually
stimulating for you yet every job has
brought has grunt work has grind has
things that aren't super exciting
meetings that you have to sit in right
but at the end of the day if the thing
you're working on big picture does
interest you the grind is a little bit
easier back when I was working out
things that didn't interest me the grind
is harder and so ask yourself what is it
about artificial intelligence big
picture that interests you and where is
this going
and then ask yourself if the you know
the daily grunt work is worth it to move
in that direction and then see maybe
there's something else in your life
that's more interesting maybe Fitness is
more interesting to you and you want to
take your technical skills into a
company that's building fitness apps I
don't know but that's the kind of stuff
that you need to figure out so if if if
you're sitting there and you're just in
your head worried about these things
you're not gonna get an answer you have
to write it down talk to people and
really figure out
you know outside of your head what why
this is the thing that you're interested
in oh yeah we get a lot of questions
here sorry I'm not gonna be able to get
to all the questions you've only got
about eight minutes left but I'm going
to try to get to as many as I can for
impostor syndrome I'm definitely not
going to be able to go deep enough on
this one but we a question I'm suffering
from impostor syndrome what can I do to
motivate myself we have to realize that
all of our thoughts positive negative
impostor or all that stuff is is exactly
that they are just thoughts they are not
the real execution of whatever it is
we're doing I mean there are
unbelievable numbers of conversations
where I'm talking to a PhD person who
says well I'm overqualified and they
don't want to pay me they want to hire
someone young and then I go talk to a
young person and they're like I'm not
qualified enough they want to hire
someone who's a PhD and it's all in our
heads the only way to get past impostor
syndrome is to say I hear it let's put
that to the side
I feel like an imposter great now who do
I go talk to in order to learn more the
more you learn the less of an imposter
you feel but we always have more to
learn so of course there's always more
to do so I mean there are people who
never overcome impostor syndrome who
still get jobs who still go do
interesting work they just you know have
to realize that this is just a thought
just a feeling and that if you can just
quiet your mind a little bit and focus
you'll get back to doing things which is
more important than thinking if you're
qualified you can think you're
unqualified and still create a great
project now if you create projects that
aren't working and this really isn't
what you're good at then that's a
different different story but seems like
that you you've identified that it's
imposter syndrome you probably do have
the skill set just don't let the
imposter syndrome stop you from creating
something just go create it and then
create something else and then go talk
to another person and then go create
something else if you just keep doing
that you never have to prove yourself
the work is proving it as you go
we are a so we have a follow-up from
Katelyn troubling find trouble finding
remote entry-level work you live in
Florida an hour from Tampa in Nantou
County taking up local freelance work
and meanwhile yeah there are a lot of
websites up work and different things
like that where you can take up some
freelance work and if you can find some
local freelance stuff like literally
just whatever it is that you do I'm
sorry don't have your job title here
just identify all the local companies
and start talking to them and see if
they need help do with what you can do
so I definitely agree you should go out
there and see who you can freelance for
100%
see if I can get one more in before the
end here maybe two
you
divine dragon hey coach I wanted some
pointers if I should pursue a master's
PhD or work to create a career details
include the following I love studying I
live in Pakistan and industry here is
messed up hmm there's a couple things
you gotta ask yourself before committing
to a master's PhD things like that is
what is your financial situation oh I'm
working remotely on a us-based start-up
full-stack developer but I prefer
algorithms and more abstract research
the lack of available window on gaining
funding for study yeah I mean the big
thing for for getting additional
education is the financial side so if if
you don't have the financial resources
you've got to focus on your career and
there and you also have to look at the
ROI on your financial on your on your
educational choices will getting a
masters or PhD get you closer to what
you want to be doing and get you paid
more if it won't then it's it's not
worth spending all that money just
because you love studying you can study
on your own and a good way to study on
your own build your own blog takes a few
minutes out of the day to start a blog
and say for the next year i'm going to
research this deeply I mean there's
countless numbers of people who have
sort of built their own MBA built their
own education so I would say uh you know
look at your financial situation if you
just have money to spare and time to
spare I guess go for it but it sounds
like you you're working on stuff you're
doing interesting things you could
probably build and um spend that time
building an online persona brand
whatever and getting more clients and
getting more work and then you know if
if you find that not having a master's
in PhD is blocking you I know there's
certain companies that won't let you
meet past a certain level if you don't
have a master's PhD but that's changing
that's that's not as required anymore
it's still
required and certain things would make
sure that that's what you're going after
if you're going to go after it
yeah so I would say if you've already
got work going on and you know what you
want to learn and you can teach yourself
then teach yourself or use a combination
of different online certification
programs and skill programs and then you
know if you do have money you do at the
time and it's really gonna help you and
give you good ROI you know a master's
isn't a bad thing but it's just
expensive and it's you know something
that takes a lot of time to get alright
that's it for today sorry we didn't get
to get to everyone's questions I'm
really really happy that you guys all
joined us today we had you know over 100
people in the chat asking great
questions thank you so much for joining
us RSVP for next week's Q&A we're gonna
be doing these every Thursday so we're
really excited to to do that you can
check out the link in the chat Karen
should be sharing it in just a second
and I please give us your feedback
there's a link in the chat to fill out a
survey I'm really excited to hear how we
can improve these in the future and if
you have more questions please address
them to me and send them to so I just
reach out on slack just send me stuff on
slack and I'll be happy to include those
questions in future videos so thank you
so much for joining us today my name is
Martin and I look forward to chatting
with you and answering your questions
again next week